Manish Mehta covers the Jets NFL writer
the New York Daily News and I don't know
if we've got a quarterback controversy
but let's start one if we don't Sam
Darnell's not encamp Manish why is he
not well well let me just say that Sam
Donnell has something in common with
Baker Mayfield he also has not thrown
interception training yeah well the
reason is a little bit more it's a
little simpler than I think people are
trying to make it it's about the
contract language in his rookie deal and
as you know with the rookie slotted wage
scale he's going to get his you know
fully guaranteed 30 million dollars but
his agent jimmy sexton NCAA are really
haggling over a point just so they can
quote-unquote get a win in this deal
because they want it offset language to
be removed and they lost all their
leverage when Baker Mayfield signed his
deal with the Browns with offset
language so at that point the agency
kind of pivots and says now the
guarantee voiced errupted that the Jets
have is not fair which is ironic because
jimmy sexton also represents Avery
Williamson who was a free agent that the
Jets signed this offseason
and Avery Williamson's contract has the
exact same language as the Sam Donald
contract and every other contract that
the Jets give out and Jimmy Sexton
didn't take any issue with that but
because he didn't win on the offset
battle for lack of a better phrase he's
trying to get a win here it's not really
in the best interest of his client given
that he's missed these first three
practices and you know I think a lot of
times ego gets involved here and that's
what we're seeing in this particular
situation I can tell you that I that Sam
Donald is a few minutes away from the
facility kind of waiting for this to all
play out and he's not happy I know the
family is not happy as well so I would
anticipate that this gets resolved
fairly soon explain to us offset
language okay it's a it's a it's a way
for teams to protect themselves in case
the player is cut before the 4-year deal
is up so in this case if Sam Donald were
cut three years into his career and
signed with the New England Patriots and
the Jets still owed Sam Donald five
million dollars for the you know those
of that 30 million dollars that he's
guaranteed and the Patriots signed
Arnold for two million dollars without
offset language the player can double
dip or get to full salaries from two
teams so in this case five million
dollars remaining from the Jets plus the
two million dollars from the Patriots he
would make seven million dollars in that
year whereas with offset provisions the
Jets are only on the hook for what they
owed him in this case five million
dollars - what the new team was going to
pay him two million so they would be on
the hook for three million dollars it
doesn't really happen that often it's
actually happened to bunch with the
Browns with their first-round picks and
their quarterbacks they haven't really
worked out so it was interesting that
Baker Mayfield made it clear to his
representatives that he knew all about
the history but he still did not want to
miss a practice and he was going to sign
a deal that included offset provisions
the other issue the issue that CAA wants
everyone to believe is now the
quote/unquote real issue is about
guarantee void structure now the Jets
are only one of four teams I believe in
the league that tie their guarantee
forfeiture language with not only
suspensions but with fines but it's not
like if Donald wore his socks too high
the Jets could void his thirty million
dollars clearly that's not going to
happen these you know suspensions and
fines are tied specifically to PE D
policy to substance abuse policy and to
a policy or or an app that could be
deemed conduct detrimental to the team
so Sam Donald punched out Todd bowls
that yes the Jets could be the Jets
could void his you know thirty million
dollars that's not going to happen
that's such an egregious case and that's
why it's not that big of a deal unless
the agent wants to make it a big deal
because they want to get a win for
themselves and for their agency
meanwhile the player suffers clearly the
team suffers because Donald it's going
to be their face as a franchise they
hope for the next decade I just think
that you have to keep in mind that the
agent works for the player and a lot of
times in this industry in this business
players defer to their agents especially
young players and ie players rookie
players and and that's why this isn't
about Sam Donald the CAA is also
representing role Quan Smith and I think
the AAA is in the right for holding
outro kwan smith because he is a
linebacker and the Bears are looking to
void guaranteed money if he's suspended
for an illegal hit and with this new
lowering helmet rule that's much more
applicable to a linebacker so I
understand the agency's position in that
case but that's not applicable for Sam
darlin and if Sam Donald flunks or fails
a steroid test and I think he should
have some of his guaranteed money voided
so I don't have an issue with the team's
stance in that case I just believe in
this particular instance the agent is
not doing right by his client and
because of that his client is suffering
the team is suffering and ultimately
depending on how long this lasts
it could affect whether Sam Donald will
be there week 1 starter because they
certainly want to give him every
opportunity over the next 5 weeks to do
that yeah that was what I was gonna
bring up Manish and that is the
likelihood that Sam darn 'old is the
starting quarterback for the Jets and
you're saying that they're holding out
hope or they're preparing for that I
don't want to put words in your mouth
but how would you describe that
situation well they wanted to evaluate
him in a vacuum you've also got Teddy
Bridgewater and Josh McCown of course
and you know there's a lot of discussion
about what a great quarterback
competition this is going to be over the
next month it's not really a quarterback
competition it's really Sam Donaldson
Arnold and whether he can prove to
Jeremy Bates and Todd Bowles that he is
ready to be the week 1 starter because
when you line up Sam Donald with Josh
McCown for example a guy who's been in
the league for 15 years you wouldn't
anticipate that a rookie would have a
better grasp of this offense and the
inner workings of you know breaking down
defenses as a guy like McHale would
McCown is always going to be better over
the next month or so so it's not about
that it's just about evaluating Donald
in a vacuum and wondering and finding
out and asking yourself is he ready to
be an NFL starting quarterback September
10th when the Jets open up in Detroit on
Monday night and if the answer to that
question is yes then the Jets are going
to start him if he needs more seasoning
they're not going to rush his
development because they do have a good
fallback option in the town and an
intriguing option in Teddy Bridgewater
so that's kind of how they laid out
their plan they wanted the lion share of
reps and the preseason to go to
Bridgewater and
Arnold and have Josh McCown kind of
waiting in the background much like he
did last year when the Jets gave Bryce
petty and Christian Hackenberg an
opportunity unfortunately neither one of
those two guys grabbed a moment and they
turned to McCown to start the season and
they'll do that again if Bridgewater or
Donald isn't ready but they want to
foster an environment where they can
properly and fairly evaluate him and
every day then he misses every practice
every meeting he misses he'll puts him a
little bit farther away from there at
reality it's never easy for the Jets
right no it's not and I think that the
the agent is kind of playing on that and
you know the Jets get a bad rap and I've
been critical to the Jets many times
over the last decade but in this
particular case I fully believe that
they're right they again they're not
doing anything different than for Sam
Donald and they are contractually for
any other player and they don't want to
have a precedent where they're changing
up something that they firmly believe in
for him because that means every future
signing whether it's a free agent or
somebody that they draft is going to
hold out for a similar provision and I
don't think it's unreasonable to say hey
you know what if you do something that's
conduct detrimental to the team you're
going to lose some of your guaranteed
money you also have to factor in Dan
there's not going to be petty about this
if he if he gets fined for an illegal
hit you know if he's trying to block
somebody there they're not going to
create ill-will and take money away from
him because again they want him to be
their future and they want him to be
around for a very long time
manoosh thank you we appreciate your
time as always that's Manish minna Jets
beat reporter NFL writer for the New
York Daily News for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]